yeah welcome to this video blitz game I
tried for the 15 minute game but I
couldn't get one so a five minute game
instead oh yeah sloth let's see what
line is going for get the usual accepted
here Mon C for ya now White has some
couple of options one interesting option
is night each form immediately asking
this Bishop where do you go now you know
we just retreat okay let's grab this and
I need to get the palm back I'm not sure
about before maybe you can reply e5 I
III years I think okay just getting them
in pawn back and III for I can always um
play later not sure if I should time
should cancel
especially the timing of castles is
interesting it's clear that i need to
castle at some point but um the exact
term move is not clear k I probably
cannot play without age three yeah I
somehow expected this some this typical
kind of active blitz meals and probably
maybe it's not so bad hmm
yeah mm-hmm actually had thought I can
just play f3 but he gives his check at
night age 5 a bit of a problem okay yes
it's a case of no way back yeah I know
he's five it takes h3i play g3 and win
the bishop yeah he can do that but he
wont to keep it anyway I think I can
play when you form this is what I'm
fought at least attacking the night and
how does he protected check ok we see it
doesn't protect it and now Queen f7 em
mmm Queen f7 isn't this winning I am
Queen f7 rook a seven of course Luke f7
takes Queen f5 mm yeah but I can take
and just play that what does he what is
he doing now don't need to do any fancy
stuff the bishop personal square on h4 I
can play we can just take on edge 30
mmm yeah still no square and maybe now I
can take with the bishop and set up in
an enormous fork okay let's do this this
is also my bed check I can also grab him
yeah my king is completely without any
bond governor
if he takes Queen takes I he doesn't um
all right so I wonder about 95 not be
five a look-see one ideas it's not bad
at all or should I just step in just
take f7
okay keep it simple
yeah my king is wide open this is
probably an relatively easy win with
enough time on the clock but with a
little time it is it is still slightly
tricky especially with nights on the
board I can get a four but it was hard
to keep it
check
a king a 88 actually yeah need to be
quick IAM time is running low
it's cut some coordination issues how it
does he protect the bishop now not easy
we move that to g7 for example I have
Bishop e3 and it's um it's a big pin
and I don't really see a good move home
but 38 seconds
check
check
check
yeah I only have one poor left this is a
problem now I don't have any ball left
check check check I morning
check yeah just trying to make a drawn
on with Queen exchange check check you
should be a force much at czech game
drums yeah what can you do with your old
time I completely wonderful was my
bishop laaste okay I need to move it yet
but it's a it's a draw anyway what what
else yeah I should probably win here
about the boat here I think why should
just win the game but check queen g5 is
better but this looks strong actually
check check p 3 check a queen a
five-year no of course just queen 85 I
am I took it 25 yeah whatever I just had
the feeling that I should have something
they are very complicated with a little
time on the clock
yeah I hope you enjoyed it a pretty
pretty crazy game I think